this was a labour win that couldn't have
been closer to home for the
conservatives the party had controlled
local government in westminster since
1964.
now for the first time the famous
streets of power here are run by a
labor-controlled city of westminster
council
london boroughs barnet and wandsworth
also fell to the labour party wandsworth
was taken after 44 years of conservative
rule
[Applause]
but despite the elation of labour's
leader kia starmer outside london labor
gains were turning out to be modest he
was nevertheless in good cheer this is a
massive turning point for the labour
party from the depths of 2019 we're back
on track now for the general election
showing what the change that we've done
the hard change we've done in the last
two years what a difference it has made
but had this been a general election the
results wouldn't have stacked up to make
kierstama prime minister
boris johnson chose to visit a school in
west london as results were coming in
the maths weren't good for the prime
minister that's right
it's midterm and it's certainly a mixed
set of results and uh we've had a tough
night in some parts of the of the
country but on the other hand in other
parts of the country you're still seeing
uh conservatives going forward and
making
quite remarkable gains
in places that haven't voted
conservative for a long time or if ever
partygate the scandal over covet rule
breaches in downing street including by
johnson himself loom large in this
election
but the overall damage to the governing
conservative party is less than expected
and for labor out of the blue something
to dampen the celebrations police have
announced they've reopened an
investigation into claims that stammer
also breached covet regulations when
drinking beer in an office with a group
of colleagues
in essence the message from london
voters doesn't reflect the mood all over
the country however the conservative
party will have to work hard to try to
quell mid-term descent
so these results aren't really a
disaster but at the very least they
serve as a big warning shot and the main
target has been boris johnson for his
wrongdoings and his style of leadership
many londoners have given a negative
verdict to the conservative party and
that's going to resonate in the
corridors of power here
andrew simmons al jazeera london